she what's amazing about you and Mark is
the amount of press that you guys have
done over the course of your career have
you ever thought about the number of
interviews you've done and the impact
that it's had no I've never thought
about the number of interviews or the
impact at all
you know we just we try to help and to
share what we're going through and we
struggles so much in our 20s that we
just feel like if people want to ask us
questions and hopefully it can help them
in any way that it's it's you know it's
our duty to do that and to give back but
you know I I don't really think about
what's out there you know how it impacts
people I do I do get some feedback that
people appreciate it and it's really
nice do you subscribe to the idea that
there is no such thing as bad press or I
mean we're seeing things sometimes in
the media where I go hmm
is this orchestrated or is this really
story and now I think more so than ever
yeah I'm so removed from that world and
from the concept of like doing press
stunts or anything you know it's just
not I don't have the time or the brain
space to do it I got two kids and I'm
trying to make a decent movie and I find
those two things to be just unbelievably
difficult to do at the same time so I
don't I don't think that much about bad
press and I I personally just thinking
about it right now I'm just like I fall
on the side of I believe in karma and I
believe in telling the truth and and
doing what you believe in and and not
lying and not and not faking anything so
you never have to watch your back I mean
that's that's my that's my philosophy of
life and and an art and everything
honestly so I'm sure it probably works
for some people but
it's not for me what about the terrence
malick approach where you know nothing
and then you're totally fascinated just
beyond belief because there's no
information I'm fascinated by terrence
malick absolutely yeah I definitely I'm
a private person so it definitely
appeals to me to be like a Coen Brothers
type person or like a Terrence Malick
type person but you know like I was
telling you before like you know young
filmmakers look up to us and they want
to know how we're doing what we're doing
and and when I hear that and I feel that
I feel moved to share it you know and to
share our process and and to try and
help people express themselves because
it was you know the hardest journey of
my life was to you know sort of like
come out with like who I am and what I
want to give to the world and if I can
help anybody get through that then
that's something that I would love to do
you